there's a really pivotal scene in the
Thanksgiving episode of the show masters
of non Angela Bassett plays a mom she's
a mother to Denise she turns to her she
says honey we're minorities and we have
to work twice as hard to get half as far
[Music]
for me imposter syndrome there was never
one big moment it was all kind of like
smaller moments one of the first ones I
felt was I went to a very diverse high
school there was like Latinos black
people Asian people
Indian people and I ended up going to
college in Providence Rhode Island I
went to this liberal arts college I was
there on a scholarship and I remember my
first day of campus it was a sea of
white people and I was so surprised and
I just thought the world was like my
high school I just I never felt such a
lack of diversity it was really shocking
to me and I felt insecure I think I
worked hard because I wanted to convince
myself that I belong there so me
imposter syndrome is a person who never
takes in their successes and always
feels like they're waiting on the next
shoe to drop or waiting on somebody to
find them out when I started my company
maybe which is a stationary company for
women of color I remember hitting these
really big milestones and one of them
was I was featured in essence magazine
six months and to starting my business
and I could never take that in I could
never say you know what this happened
because I was bold enough to reach out
to the magazine this happened because I
started this company from scratch it was
never about what I did it was about well
maybe it was just the universe but it
wasn't about my hard work dedication to
making that happen my first paid
internship was a non-profit in DC and it
was for an internship program for my
college and other colleges in California
and also had a couple Ivy League schools
involved with it I was one of maybe five
students that had a paid internship and
there were about 200 students in the
program I kept telling myself that I
didn't deserve to have a paid internship
the IB kids didn't have a paid
internship it didn't make sense to me
despite having worked before and being a
politics major and being in DC where
politics is such a big thing I just told
myself that it was a lot kids who I felt
were more qualified or deserved it more
than I did didn't have the same
experience that I had once I started
becoming a manager and leading teams and
being you know the head of departments
and things like that more often than not
not only am I the only woman
but I'm the only person of color when
you're a black woman you don't get to be
mediocre you don't get to walk into the
place and say you know it I'm just gonna
be alright today I think black women are
taught that we are not deserving as much
as I hate to say that and I think that
it's stuck with me unfortunately
I work hard and consciously I feel that
I'm deserving of things but
subconsciously I don't feel that way I
attributed everything to luck as opposed
to just attributing it to me
I think impostor syndrome is something
that as women of color we're always
gonna come across and it's really how do
you handle it feeling alone you know
feeling like a fraud feeling like wait
how did I get here
do I deserve to be here and there's
pressure as a black woman to always be
strong to always be fearless to always
have this hardened exterior because if
we show any part of ourselves that is
actually human then that makes us weak
or that makes us less valuable you have
to keep telling myself that everyone
does not necessarily know more than me
or deserve to be here any more than I do
these are things that I have to remind
myself every single day because if I
don't I'll fall back into this place
where it's like okay wait what happens
when somebody doesn't think I'm good
enough or am I actually good enough
there's that old saying fake it till you
make it and I just kind of try to do
that you know until I realize I'm not
faking it anymore I'm just like I'm just
laying it